here's the next one i want to show you
you and peter shift going back and forth
on twitter
uh uh do you have the one in regards to
gold is this the one in regards to gold
uh tyler is this the one so you're going
back okay so also instead of just
posting ill relevant replies michael
galbraith to the table to what peterson
set goal because he's a big proponent of
gold cios who follow michael sailors
asinine advised to plug their balance
sheets into bitcoin to hedge against
they expect an annual inflation rate of
two percent now down as much as thirty
four percent of their hunch in one month
uh uh that's 17 years of expected
inflation losses time to pull the plug
michael saylor responds
with returns
on gold versus bitcoin then he responds
also instead of just posting irrelevant
replies to my tweets why don't you agree
to debate me so far you have turned down
every opportunity to do so it's clear to
me
uh that you're afraid to actually
confront me and defend your ridiculous
views so you
take your cowards way out by the way we
invited him to be on the podcast today
he said get me a private jet and we
invited him to be on the zoom and he
said he's not available i'm just letting
you know we don't get typically people
saying get me a private jet that was his
request
and then you say it's not clear what we
could debate we would debate your
position appears to be buy some more
gold buy some gold or silver or gold
stocks or government bonds or corporate
bonds or dividend stocks or value stocks
or emerging market stocks or small
company stocks or anything
really just not too much the debate
would be about bitcoin you think it's
digital gold i think it's digital fool's
gold you think everyone who doesn't own
it should buy it i think everyone who
wants it should sell it and the
fundamental point here is
is
you have to give the world a solution to
their problem not just be a critic
if you want to be a critic you can
criticize everything but but what's his
answer if you listen if you listen to
peter's debates what he says is he only
has five percent of his portfolio
invested in gold which means that he has
95 invested in something else but what
is the something else
and the point is he you know you're back
in the same you know hedge fund shuffle
mentality it's like just give me all
your money and i'm just going to shuffle
it with random 95
opacity on random stuff
back and forth but don't question it
what about the five if it was it was a
recommendation he would own more than 50
percent of his portfolio in the gold but
he doesn't believe in it
so but his argument would be his
argument would be i don't recommend
people to buy fifty percent i recommend
people to buy two to five percent that's
his position he doesn't have an answer
to the
that that means that you're going to
lose 95 of your wealth so what's the
answer so and your point is that
diversity by the way i already i have a
debate if you go online and you google
michael saylor gold debate you'll find a
pretty good debate that's got more than
2 million views right now where i go
point by point
through the differences between bitcoin
and gold
the issue with with peter is
peter's not offering a solution to the
world
right he's simply
trolling bitcoin and he's not trolling
bitcoin with any
any real concrete criticism other than
he just doesn't like it right like but
wouldn't the world so mike if you guys
did have a debate
wouldn't the world benefit i guess the
question is i don't realize he's not he
doesn't he doesn't have a concrete
argument but you're not dodging a debate
with him
i i don't see the point of debate when
peter buys a billion dollars worth of
gold
then i'll have a debate with him
so you're saying you don't see him as a
true believer even in the he says hey
gold is your hedge against as pat uh uh
properly pointed out to him on the fox
interview that peter and pat had said
listen peter you're selling armageddon
to sell gold yeah and you're saying and
yet peter only owns five peters short
gold peter is a peter is anti-everything
for example he's got more investment in
gold stocks gold miners than gold well
gold miners are short gold
gold miners incentive is to dump as much
gold on the market as possible as fast
as possible
if you read the balance sheets of the
gold miners what you'll find is they
don't hold gold as an asset so so gold
miners don't believe gold is money if
they did they wouldn't sell it they'd
buy it
and peter doesn't believe gold is money
if he did he wouldn't allocate 95 of his
wealth to something other than it
and ultimately
the fundamental issue with peter is you
know he's just debated you know he's
debated this issue for a decade
all of his argument is just i don't like
bitcoin he hasn't come up with anything
worth refuting that i can see and if you
go online you'll find three four five
six peter schiff debates
and he just doesn't say anything other
than just bark the person that he's
debating with so i can't see it's
constructive this is a reasonably
constructive uh debate if you go to me
and frank gestra where we actually had a
lot of
back and forth
fundamentally though
find me somebody in the world that has
invested more than 50
of a portfolio and gold
or at a billion dollar level
like my my position is pretty clear i've
invested almost four billion dollars in
bitcoin
and i'm not telling you you need to
invest half your portfolio in it i'm
just saying that i think that it is it
is money it is an asset it will
appreciate in value and one can create a
strategy where it is the the dominant uh
part of the strategy
there are other people that have
invested in companies amazon
amazon was jeff bezos strategy i get it
big tech
other people have bought city blocks in
new york city that's a that's a valid
strategy so investing in property or
investing in technology is a valid
strategy but on the other hand find me
someone that is actually bet five
billion dollars on gold where it
constitutes more than fifty percent of
their portfolio and it's their own money
and peter's not one
peter hasn't bet on gold peter's betting
on gold going down he's buying the
bitcoin the gold miners that are dumping
the gold making the gold price decay so
that doesn't make any sense if you dig
into the gold miner balance sheets
read read the
the two three biggest gold miners what
you'll find is
they over mine the gold dump the gold
then they pay an income tax then they've
divided out their excess and pay a
dividend tax then they pay off their
debt which is two percent so another way
to say it is they would rather uh loan
money out to the world for two percent
interest than whole gold
that's how bad they don't like gold
right and they're the ones that mine the
goal it's it's an it's a crippling
indictment of the entire industry
right that they think it's going to zero
that's why they keep dumping the gold on
the market
find me somebody
that really believes in gold in fact
every single gold proponent you'll find
on the internet if you listen to them
they'll start their conversation with
well first of all i don't recommend you
invest more than five or ten percent of
your money in gold it's just like it's a
hedge thing so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]